[Music]
good evening everybody my name is ganesh
taylor and i'm your host this evening
for the debate about the time of our
lives being is found in the present
for the moment of consciousness is all
there is
or so zen buddhist philosophy teaches
the moment of experience has also been
central to western philosophy since
decath and the value of the now
currently fashionable from london to la
yet as marx argued is not the point of
life to change it for the better and not
simply to contemplate it
does only the present exist
and is embracing the present the path to
truth and fulfillment or is this a
dangerous fantasy and the present an
illusion a distraction from the real
task of creating the future
or can we give an account of time that
explains the uniqueness of the present
and the sea of time that surrounds us
this evening
we are joined by three uh illustrious
speakers first of all we have sarah
jaffe who is a journalist columnist and
podcast co-host covering the politics of
power from the workplace to the streets
she was one of the first reporters to
cover occupy and the fight for 15
and has appeared on numerous radio and
television programs
she's also the author of the acclaimed
books work won't love you back and
necessary trouble americans in revolt
secondly we're also joined by poet and
philosopher john petch
who holds a phd in philosophy from the
university of georgia
his dissertation explores why
jeans delus
henry bergson and gw leipnic all
intertwined continuity with
heterogeneity whether considering how a
life dissipates time or a body diffuses
force
his ongoing research dances between
philosophy maths and art and he has
published several works of anomalous
poetry welcome john
last but absolutely by no means least uh
ron persa is a management professor at
san francisco state university a zen
priest and a cultural critic
whose viral article beyond mindfulness
open the floodgates for the mindfulness
backlash
he is the author of eight books
including the widely discussed
mindfulness how mindfulness became the
new capitalist spirituality and his
works center on the challenges of
introducing buddhist thoughts into
modern individualist secular western
consumer capitalism what a rip roaring
lineup we have there
so
uh without any further ado
i want to
let you all uh give me your three minute
pitches
uh addressing the following question
is the present moment all that exists
and is it all that matters
run your up first what do you think
um not in the way we think i would argue
that
what we have on offer is
a very narrow conception of the present
moment
within a particular understanding of
time
that's based on a linear temporal order
and what we call reality or existence is
located
so-called located in this ephemeral and
momentary present
but it's continuously changing as the
next moment always arrives so on the one
hand
i would argue that there really is no
present moment it's a mental construct
perhaps even just a label and it's
problematic i think to believe that the
present is all that matters for a number
of reasons
for example the
popular practice of mindfulness
exhorts us to be mindful and attentive
to the present moment but the idea is
that we would be less stressed and
happier if we only could stop ruminating
about the past or the future and just
drop into this pristine present moment
however i think if we looked more
closely we would see that such an
activity presupposes
a subject who is already deficient in
some way where the task is somehow to
pin down this
mental object to grab hold of what
amounts to kind of an elusive and
perpetual moving target
i i think we would i think we would
discover rather quickly that
what we call the present moment it's
already shifted it's becoming the past
so even the act of trying to pay
attention itself requires time or
duration
so
by the time such attention occurs
the moment labeled as the presence
already passed away so in a way it's
kind of like a feudal task like chasing
a after a mirage in a in a desert
and
so i think that's problematic and just
one point about zen is that um i don't
think zen really says anything
or offer us anything conceptually
about the present moment or about
consciousness
it may point at
what we might think of as timelessness
or
the infinitude of being but pointing
isn't the same thing
and our monitor our modern understanding
of the present is very different from
this more timeless now
because that timeless now is completely
non-dual completely non-conceptual so i
think what we have on offer here i hate
to sound crude is a very cheap
uh counterfeit kind of present momentism
or here and now ism
where the presence turned into kind of
like a fetish
and you could bring marx into the
equation because
marx talks about fetishes that sort of
what people sort of irrationally have
reverence for something and the present
moments become like the
modern grail uh it's very fashionable
but it's really not new we can go back
to the gurus in the 1970s such as rahm
dasa's book
uh
be here now
and more recently eckhart tolle's book
the power of now
but i think what's common
here is that the the present moments
become sort of imbued with
some sort of magical power
that if we just live in the present
moment all will supposedly be well very
interesting all right well thank you for
kicking us off there ron
um
john
wha what do you what do you think
so i would say no not at all is the
president all that exists and i would
kind of agree with some of the points
ron was making as well but i think i
would phrase it very differently and
maybe try to open up some differences
between us
um i like ron how you were saying that
the present is more complex than it's
usually accounted for it's not a simple
thing at all but it's this
already kind of structured thing that
we're kind of interfacing with all the
time
um so i would say that right the present
is not all that exists and the present
is
thereby not the most important thing but
not because time is some kind of an
illusion or a mental construct or
anything of that kind or even like a
kind of cultural hallucination or
something like that it's because
the present is the kind of least
consequential part of this vast kind of
you could say durative structure i'm
using the the word durative from the
notion of duration and things enduring
um and it's kind of less the pat or
sorry it's less the present that
matters because you have this vast
seething past that's always kind of
informing and
informing the present and insisting
uh
on acting in different ways within the
present and so because you have to
interact because everything has a
certain kind of past that determines
what it is and how it continues to
unfold in time that you can never reduce
everything to the present
and nor can you make the present a kind
of merely mental construct of some kind
but it is in a real sense the way that
things take time involves the kind of
past that they've had
and
that
is part of who and what they are and how
they differentiate themselves from other
things so we always have to kind of
inter
we always have to deal with the past i
mean we always have to
confront the different ways that things
take times and the long histories that
inform different things
do you think that that's all that
matters
do i think that
well okay so i do think that how things
take time is in a certain way all that
matters it's as on ray barricks and a
philosopher that our love says it's kind
of the most substantial thing of all
even more substantial than kind of a
thing's material or bodily presence in a
certain way so i do think that time in
the way things take time is
fundamental in a very real way
uh but i don't think again that taking
time is reducible to present time taking
interesting sarah
what are your thoughts is it all that
exists
i am not a philosopher um
but i
the thing that i thought of and and sort
of got annoyed by this question because
it's impossible to live in the present
if you are constantly worrying about
where your next meal or rent check is
coming from if you're paying off debts
from your past and terrified of being
evicted in the future
and so
um
yeah that
just before i open zoom to sign on for
this panel i was reading a new york
times article about a bill in the state
of california that would require amazon
and other warehouse employers to
disclose their productivity quotas
that in order to make sure that labor
law that you know requires things like
bathroom breaks was being upheld and in
the story there was this line
i quote an amazon official raised
concerns that some employees would abuse
more generous allotments of time for
using the bathroom
so yeah
um that's a perfect illustration of the
fact that for so much of many of our
most of our adult lives our time is
actually not our own
and so the sort of admonitions and as
ron noted that are often now these days
coming from inside the company to be
mindful and live in the present
um are another way of controlling that
time
so the first thing that of course comes
to my mind then is working time and the
hours that we spend on the clock are
essentially
um
already given up and depending on where
you work how much control you have over
that time um if you're in an amazon
warehouse as noted it's incredibly
incredibly structured and how long you
get to pee
is literally taken into account when
they decide whether they're going to
fire you or not
so
when we're thinking about
time as a thing that we measure as a
society
that in itself sort of comes into
most people's lives as part of
capitalist work discipline
um i spent the afternoon reading ep
thompson on the introduction of
basically time discipline
and
fun things like um you know the way that
the clock
was uh
itself an object of struggle in a lot of
workplaces um that the
fight for a shorter working day
which marx writes about which many
people write about was central to the
concerns of workers for the last several
hundred years
um you know back to the 1700s
and
i i left this line from thompson these
the first generation of factory workers
were taught by their masters the
importance of time the second generation
formed their short time committees in
the ten hour movement the third
generation struck for overtime or time
and a half they had accepted the
categories of their employers and
learned to fight back within them they
had learned their lesson that time is
money only too well
and i think looking forward to the
future because i guess that's what i'm
talking about here it is fascinating
that once again after the pandemic which
skewed and i'm sure we'll talk about
this more everybody's perception of time
in so many weird ways
we are talking once again about shorter
working hours and people are working
around organizing around shortening the
working week once again
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas
you